[Music]
last July after several delays Godzilla
vs Kong was released marking the most
successful film of the pandemic to date
with box office takings of almost 450
million US Dollars and mostly positive
reviews it was obvious that his sequel
would be made at some point about a year
after the release there is now first
concrete information available as
comicbook.com has learned at Godzilla vs
Kong sequel is being shot in the
Australia instead of Queensland although
the project is still without an official
title the announcement of the filming
location promises an imminent startup
shooting additionally reports are
accumulating regarding a possible
release date for the new monsterverse
film as per The Hollywood Reporter the
sequel is supposed to be released on
March 15 2024 and follow up on the
events of the predecessor more is not
known about the plot so far behind the
camera Adam Wingard is back in charge of
directing while Downton Abbey actor Dan
Stevens has already been cast as the
first leading man we expect fact more
details as soon as filming has
officially begun there's more good news
from the monsterverse and it is about
this still Untitled live action Apple TV
plus series as the streaming service
revealed there are already a number of
actors who are officially part of the
Godzilla series you can get a first
visual impression on legendary's
official Twitter account the cast
includes Pachinko actress Anna savai who
plays the former teacher and G day
Survivor Kate she embarks on a journey
to Japan to settle Family Matters she
will be joined by a dope actress Kirsty
Clemens she plays may a U.S axle in
Japan who despite her sometimes harsh
demeanor has a strong protective
Instinct the third member of the cast is
Joe Tippett who most recently appeared
in the HBO series mayor of East Town he
plays Tim and office employee who would
like for nothing more than to be a
secret agent this gets him into trouble
from time to time due to his resulting
overconfidence the last two actors are
the zaistar Eliza lazowsky and Hollywood
who respectively portraying experienced
agent named Duvel and a young curious
man named kentaro Chris black who has
already appeared as a writer and
producer on Star Trek Enterprise will
serve as showrunner also joining the
team is Hawkeye author Matt fraction who
will pen the script Joby Harold and Tori
tunnel of safe house pictures as well as
Hiro matsuoka and takamasu arita of tohu
have been hired as producers
unfortunately there is no release date
for the Apple TV plus series yet
in the past couple of days there were
some new pieces of information and
images about the upcoming Avatar the way
of water the pictures which were
exclusively published by Empire magazine
show many new and old characters and
definitely make you want to see more of
the Avatar sequel which is expected to
be released in September and one image
we get to see actress Kate Winslet for
the first time in her new role as ronal
Ronald is a tribal Chief who leads an
underwater tribe of Navi alongside
tonawari who's played by Cliff Curtis in
fact she's also pregnant although you
cannot tell from the published image and
that won't stop her from engaging in
battle Kate Winslet's appearance in
Avatar 2 is by the way the second
collaboration between her and James
Cameron the first of course being the
global hit Titanic another picture shows
sigoni Weaver whose return has also been
known for a long time many people were
surprised by this since her character Dr
Grace Augustine did in fact die in the
first part as she herself disclosed in
an interview she won't be returning to
that role either but instead to that of
the teenage adopted daughter Kiri who's
been fostered by Jake and the theory
this is a pretty big surprise because it
means that the 72 year old weaver will
now play a Young Navi in her teens made
possible by motion capture and digital
Rejuvenation a real challenge for the
actress but one that she seems to have
enjoyed immensely another attorney who
was presumed dead is Stephen Lang asked
Colonel Miles quarrich he's the first
Parts antagonist and was visibly pierced
by several arrows for him too it has now
become clear in what form he will make
his comeback on one of the pictures you
can see him in his new Avatar body
apparently the consciousness of the
villain has outlived his physical death
so now he continues his existence inside
his new blue body and is certainly
anything but happy about his supposed
advice at the hands of the navi this
would make him physically equal to the
natives of Pandora and even a more
dangerous adversary than before in
General the RDA seems to have become
even more powerful in addition to
improved avatars they have also built a
new city called Bridgehead with the help
of various machines and tools they now
want to exploit the unobtainium reserves
in Pandora's Seas other images feature a
new whale creature a group of Navi and
two thematically fitting covers from
Empire magazine James Cameron also has
some things to say to Empire he compared
the upcoming Avatar movies with a Lord
of the Rings saga the big difference
between the Lord of the Rings and Avatar
however is that the former could be
based on a book series while Cameron had
to create the template on his own so to
speak that at least helps to explain the
very long weight of 13 years between
Parts 1 and 2. Avatar the way of water
will hit theaters on December 16 2022.
a few days ago the last two episodes of
stranger things season 4 were released
on Netflix with a total of almost 4
hours of season finale the fans were
created to a real spectacle that
directly wets the appetite for the fifth
and final season serious craters Matt
and Russ Duffer have been shallowed with
praise for the current season they
initially announced that they would be
taking a vacation this month from the
first week of August they will then
start working on their script of season
5. it is known that the general idea of
the series finale has already been
defined for quite some time as The
Duffer Brothers have often said in the
past the story of the popular troop from
Hawkins was already set before the first
camera was even rolling while we were
particularly happy to spend time with
overlung episodes in season 4 that will
change in season 5 and the happy sad
confused podcast the two talked about
the fact that the running time of the
episodes will be cut back to a normal
level this is not true for the very last
episode though it is supposed to be at
least as epic as the finale of the Lord
Rings The Return of the King they want
to give the viewers enough time for the
emotional farewell of the characters
which is surely just the right decision
for such a popular series there should
also not be any major introduction in
the First episodes because as the end of
season 4 already shows that protagonists
have more than enough to do there are
also a few informative statements from
Hopper actor David Harbor in regards to
the filming he revealed to the British
GQ that shooting will start next year
and that release in the middle of 2024
is thus considered realistic we are
definitely excited and look forward to
more news about stranger things season
5.
Danny believes Dune from last year won
six Oscars making it the movie with the
most awards at this year's Academy
Awards the Blockbuster was well received
not only by the jury but also by fans
and film critics hence the sequel was
already agreed upon shortly after the
movie's release escolida reports the
so-called pre-shooting will already kick
off this month in Italy more precisely
after Tomba Brienne and the province of
Treviso the modern work of art fits
perfectly with a Monumental architecture
of Dune at the end of the month the
proper shooting is scheduled to begin in
Budapest under the direction of dead
evil enough in terms of the cast we are
going to see some familiar faces from
the first part again including Timothy
chalamet as Paula tradis Zendaya as
Johnny Rebecca Ferguson s lady Jessica
Javier bartima stilgar and Stellan
Skarsgard as Baron Vladimir harkanin
other confirmed newcomers include Leia
sedu as lady Margot and Christopher
Walken as empress Chatham IV while
Florence Pugh will also make her debut
as Princess Ireland along with Austin
Butler as fate router in spite of the
good news regarding the shooting start
there is still a little Downer as far as
the release date is concerned as told by
The Hollywood Reporter Warner Brothers
has decided to postpone Dune part 2.
nevertheless fan should not worry too
much because the theatrical release has
been adjusted only by a few weeks from
October 2023 to November 17 2023. in
addition to Dune part 2 A series called
Dune The Sisterhood is curling
production the spin-off revolves around
the Benet Jess red and the pilot will
even be directed by Danny vilnep himself
yet it is not known when exactly this
series will kick off
new Star Wars series and or will be
released on Disney plus this August
already a few days ago there was not
only a first picture but also some
initial information about the series on
the picture which was exclusively
published by Empire magazine we can see
Stellan Skarsgard and Diego Luna Luna
will again take on the role of the Rebel
cash and Andor who previously made a
fateful appearance in Rogue One Star
Wars story this series however is
intended to function as a sort of
prequel to Rogue one and shed new light
on the character of the titular hero
serious Creator Tony Gilroy revealed
further details in an interview with
Empire magazine accordingly The
Five-Year storyline will be told within
two seasons the episodes will be broken
down into different story arcs in season
1 and 2 that would be four story arcs of
Three episodes each making a total of 24
episodes in between the story Parts
there will always be some time jumps to
illustrate the long duration of the
Rebellion season 1 will cover one year
only while season 2 will take us through
the remaining four years leading up to
Rogue one it sounds like an interesting
concept that sets and or apart from
existing live action series such as the
Mandalorian or Obi-Wan Kenobi and is
unique to the Star Wars universe as such
in addition to Skarsgard and Luna the
cast also includes Forest Whitaker's
sajirea Ben Mandel's Ness or synchronic
and Genevieve O'Reilly as mon mothma we
are eagerly awaiting the premiere of
Andor on Disney Plus on August 31st
2022.
that was our news for this week if you
want to know more about the upcoming
Fast and Furious 10 we recommend our
in-depth original from last Sunday also
check out the first trailer for this
dust on in Amsterdam with Margot Robbie
Christian Bale Robert De Niro and many
more feel free to have a look around on
our Channel see you next time
laughs
[Music]